a cyberpunk 2077 event is coming in June
we've got a new trailer for the Last of
Us part two dropping tomorrow and halo 2
anniversary is coming to PC I'm chastity
and this is your safe state for May 5th
happy Cinco de Mayo if you're itching
for more about cyberpunk 2077
CD Projekt RED tees that an event for
the game is coming in June it's called
night city wire and it's happening on
June 11th which would have been the last
day of III if it were still on we don't
know what CD Projekt RED is planning for
the show but Knight City is the
sprawling mega city where the game is
set cyberpunk 2077 is set for release on
September 17th on ps4 Xbox one and PC
what are you hoping to see at this event
I hope that Keanu calls in I think we
could all use more Keanu right now and
even more events a new series called
Xbox 2020 will air monthly and it sounds
like each episode will be in the style
of Nintendo directs the first Xbox 2020
is the May seventh stream we talked
about in yesterday's episode of safe
state we'll get to see third-party
gameplay trailers from a variety of Xbox
partners and it's also where we'll get
our first look at Assassin's Creed
Valhalla gameplay the Xbox 2020 stream
in July will focus on first party Xbox
game studios titles so we could possibly
see Halo infinite gameplay then we'll
get more streams each month for the rest
of the year what games are you hoping to
see during these Xbox 2020 events and
now listen to this is this the Xbox
series X boot screen
[Music]
Microsoft teased the inside Xbox stream
with a brief video featuring the series
X logo it's a simple splash screen and
sound which is in line with Microsoft's
plans to make the series X branding
simpler closed captions of the video
read new Xbox sound and the video
description mentions booting up inside
Xbox so this may just be the series X
Start screen what's your favorite
console boot up screen mine is the Sega
Genesis
suit up Spartans because halo 2
anniversary is coming to PC this month
halo 2 anniversary is coming to the PC
version of the Master Chief collection
on May 12th halo 2 anniversary on PC
will feature a complete redesign of its
audio and cutscenes to align with modern
standards similar to halo combat Evolved
Anniversary from 2011 halo 2 is the
third game to be added to the PC version
of the Master Chief collection following
reach and the original combat Evolved
the remaining three entries in the PC
collection will be added later in 2020
finishing with Halo 4 are you gonna play
halo 2 anniversary on PC which Halo game
is your personal favorite The Last of Us
part 2 is getting a new trailer very
soon like in a few hours I'm not wearing
a watch your watch is broken Naughty Dog
tweeted a teaser featuring Joel and
Ellie's voices the full trailer will
debut tomorrow May 6th at 7 a.m. Pacific
and 10 a.m. Eastern this comes just
after director Neil druckmann said the
game has gone gold meaning the final
code is being uploaded to the
PlayStation Store and pressed to disk
that locks am the new June 19th release
date what are you hoping to learn from
the new trailer and you can watch the
full trailer on GameSpot when it drops
and that's your safe safe for Tuesday
I'm chastity and you can find me on
twitter @jrfromptc
[Music]